what do you think it is about and this
is a question at the award shows you see
the award shows and it seems like the a
lot of the performers have a very very
similar political ideology okay let me
just say this
I'm feel very strongly about this people
say on Twitter oh why don't you just go
back to being Hollywood why don't you
just go and just actin and don't get
political we are Americans first then we
are man and woman then we are whatever
religion we are and then we are
professional but we are Americans first
we think American we feel for our
country and we have every right to be
thoughtful about what is affecting us
also so that [ __ ] about go back and
being Hollywood go back and just being
an actor is the stupidest thing I have
ever heard
right right was the asset the award
shows not why do they express the
opinions but why is do you think it is
that there's really one ideology that is
like 92 no in order to create art you
must come from an emotional place first
it is um as an actor you've got to be on
top of your emotionality in order to
convince other people to come with you
into the story not with the story but go
bring them into the story we are
emotional beings dancers are emotional
painters are emotional writers for the
most part of fiction are emotional and
you know when you are emotional and
you're looking at the well-being of our
entirety of our country of the country
we were born in and loved you're going
to have an ideology that probably is
more humane do you think though that
sometimes the way Hollywood comes across
and I say Hollywood with with that exact
you know mentality because it is sort of
aside from respect for you the one
viewpoint a lot of times it comes across
as is it's almost like a moral
high-ground like since they're coming
from this place where emotionally they
feel like what they're doing is you know
why is good versus evil no no I will
tell you
that you just you know you weed it out
just the way they're in every profession
there are people you listen to and
people who are [ __ ]
people you listen to and people who
don't know what they're talking about
when Meryl Streep gave her speech she
was completely engaged from her being
and meant what she was saying instead of
going oh yeah we're right and you're
wrong everybody's got an opinion but
we've got ours people have got theirs
and I respect that yeah on my side on
their side it doesn't matter I'm I want
to hear maybe I'm wrong maybe I will
learn maybe I can take something that I
hear from an opposition point of view
and enrich my life with it see that's
fair like but it's see people today just
keep trying to shut down opinions that's
right that's what we're young in America
now it's crazy we came here we this
country was built on the idea of being
able to be who you are right